sie sollten aufpassen dass ihr das mehl
von der herdplatte
er macht das mal man muss da und markus
ritter und beförderte troy davis in der
zweiten klasse gelernt oder vom
jugendhaus genoss war da nicht
eigentlich bin ich 100 meter runter und
dass man sich ja so wenn du noch nicht
herunter hitze gut ausgedacht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
erhalte ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ich wollte eigentlich heute ein video
zusammen mit heiko drehen
der ist leider nicht erschienen deswegen
mache ich das nur alleine ist ja das war
ein richtig guter gibt es nichts mehr
dafür pipeline ist gut und zwar haben
wir heute was spezielles vormarsch ist
schon informationen in coca cola machen
wir heute so ein krasses weihnachtsbaum
machen eigentlich das was wir beide
überhaupt nicht können und das ist bank
rechne ich aber wir haben zwischen der
weg ist das ziel und ich glaube hier
will er jetzt auf diesem weg ist ja
genau also ich habe gestern meine
zuschauer auf install und gefragt ob der
patient rezept haben und ich habe
wirklich eine menge bekommen
man muss leider sagen das meiste davon
war das gleiche rezept neulich hab
gedacht das macht michael baar
weil das ist glaube ich dann auch am
einfachsten so gehabt und zwar backen
heute so zimt rollen sind rollen ich
glaube es rechts 15 17 schnell mit ja
das ist so gewollt sind
cage wollte weil ich sehr genau
ich weiß es auch nicht den genauen
fachausdruck aber gut ich würde sagen wo
ist schon manchmal auch schon ihre ich
probiert zum ersten mal hier die neue
sorte coca cola zimt oder zucker himmel
gerichtet
also ich bin gespannt ja meine spieler
nicht immer stimmen
na gut dann würde ich sagen ach so bevor
ich es vergesse passagier hat natürlich
noch weiter gegen das letzte um so ein
bisschen als wenn wir nicht weiterkommen
sagte da die bank helfen
deswegen marie ist fünfter wagen gerade
literat du musst uns manchmal tages
dürfte wir sind aber nur 2 deswegen von
wir sind ein motorrad so gut ich wolle
man das rezept raus und einen start als
erstes brauchen wir 250 gramm weizenmehl
weißen weil ich hier eigenen kasse
bereits mails und jetzt wollt ihr doch
vielleicht als lästig ok dann würde ich
sagen
250 gramm mehl falls du irgendwann
einfach hast dann sage ich ja muss
während wir so auch schneller ein
was man auf 250 ist nicht verwechseln
und in welchem medikament nicht
milligramm bzw
perfekt take off einer gewissen diktatur
du als nächstes eine gestrichenen
teelöffel backpulver 1 gleich zu beginn
des gipfels scharf so perfekt zu mir
noch nie das muss ich jetzt geschmiert
müsste darüber streiten weil ich mag das
genügen meist reifen
sie braucht man gestrichen dafür so
passt ein großer wir machen ja so macht
um das mal passiert es ordentlich was
drauf so man jetzt so die wirklich muss
man immer den arzt sind gestrichen real
wo es drei mal hier rein lassen
lieber ein bisschen mehr drin ist hier
genauso ein kluger weise so jetzt müssen
wir die übrigen zutaten noch hinzufügen
und alles mit einem mixer vermehren
wir haben jetzt noch 75 gramm zucker 75
jetzt ein paket parmelin zucker ja ein
ganzes pariert hatte man doch in kleinen
paket 1 passiert ist aber sie sind also
dann kann ich mich eigentlich auch
selber ein tun stöhnt schon ganz
normales wichtig weil es kaum noch eine
prise science ist wie ein ei größe
entwickelt das kind richtig mache dass
ich sage mal wie ich das gemerkt wenn
man nimmt einfach ein glas so in dem das
hier bekannte und dann hat das auch mit
move is ja ich weiß nicht aber auch
lange so also ihr könnt ihr mal schauen
so sieht es jetzt gerade aus so voll so
standardmäßig also jeder teig sieht ja
eigentlich so hause ja wir brauchen
jetzt nur 125 gramm butter
wir sind jetzt gerade auf die grandiose
idee gekommen sind auch die berlinale
ist auch noch die butter auf zu werden
weil sonst haben wir ein problem weil
wir nicht ungehört wir sollten aufpassen
dass sie das mehl von der herdplatte
bestimmen er macht das mal vorsichtig
sind ja ich habe das noch nie so gemacht
ich habe irgendwie machst du denn button
ja ich habe aber immer mit milch und so
weist so mama wenn du das liest schöne
grüße
das habe ich dem jungen eigentlich nein
ich habe auch euch okay nur damit ist
das ja ist gerade durch
und jetzt umrühren
der weihnachtsmann würden wir zum
beispiel zwischen will ich eine
riesengroße jetzt kann man eigentlich
das schon so mit der hand noch machen
kommt nicht ganz so weit haben sie eine
küchenrolle ja das wäre auf jeden fall
ein brettchen und jetzt hast du dich
drauf du bist richtig kasse gut es geht
nämlich jetzt mit 50 ich glaube schon
dass es geht erstmal bis ausweiten dann
sind verlängern
[Musik]
es ist gut dass man muss sich ja auch
einfach nur mal zu helfen will kommen
wir zum nächsten step die füllung sogar
mit zimt mischen teig auf leicht
bemehlten arbeitsfläche zu einem
rechteck von etwa 35 mal
1935 zum teil platte mit wasser
bestreichen und die zum zug kam ich
schon auch streuen
den teig längst verlieren so dass zwei
kleine rechtecke entstehen und dann
müssen wir es nur noch so in einer halb
zentimeter große streifen schneiden die
zugangstür zu noch ein bisschen hin zu
gast sind ja einfach frei nach schnauze
das war schön schöner schiffe zu stoppen
heißt und gigantisch sind ist so
aromatisch ja auch nicht so lecker eines
perfekt das ist ja okay wenn ihr das
sagt so 100 prozent trotzdem kann man
den griff bekommen genauso wie ihr von
der neuen korb ziehen müssen die schöne
schmiese und jetzt hat das kommt einfach
so verteilt natürlich auch noch
verteilen wir müssen dieses fleisch am
besten einfach als universal nicht
anzupacken
ich verstehe ja genau so muss es so ja
und dann müssen dass ein und dann ist
mir die konten besser jemand die
renditen unter regel ist man eher nein
wir müssen wieder darunter waren zu dumm
man muss
eine zweite kasse geleert war verblutet
genau das war nicht eigentlich glücklich
schätzen sie die mittel
dies macht mainz sich kaputt des karl
kamer
ich kann da gar nicht hingucken ich bin
wir kommen uns voll bewusst ok erholen
ohne groll oder wenn die dann nämlich
bestimmt jetzt drückt sich nicht weiter
zu ihm wenn ihr dann nämlich geschnitten
sind und dann aufwachen dann liest aus
wie neu geboren so besser also keinen
stress okay dass messungen brauchen wir
aber dafür jetzt kannst du viel zu dicke
eineinhalb zentimeter genau jung genau
hörgenau dass irgendwann das ist die
bittere keine einen halben zentimeter
und mir doch nicht nein das hier war ein
halber die mittel angeht ein halber
zentimeter
ich weiß ja bka die tagaus gehört da
guckt gut aussieht wie hp machen sollte
ich wollte das schon so viele kommentare
walter ihr könnt ja mal garnicht backen
ich habe noch nie behauptet dass in
bayern können oder unterhält zu 180 grad
sodass steht hier so leute oben mal
vorgeheizt und jetzt 180 grad gebiet von
4 15 minuten war ja dann würde ich sagen
wir sehen uns in 15 minuten haben wir
das
[Musik]
könnte ja nicht so lecker also jetzt
dürfen wir die sind räume aussehen legen
wir auch so ein bisschen aus wäre dass
schokolade zwischen oder warten wir
nehmen jetzt welcher ist der beste der
hier unterrichtet hatte zwischen
vorkommen ich würde mir nie wieder darf
ein h
also liebes heißer wird könnte doch
wieder großen kurven und lieben
also jetzt genauso hat sich mein recht
gut gar nicht schon ein bisschen zu
kommen ich bin der kritik ist das blech
nicht unterschrieben heißt also ich
glaub ich hab noch nie so leckere kekse
selber gemacht hier verschuldungskrise
wo früher so fünf sechs mal
es ist ein roman oder deine mama ganz
sauber oder in bremen ist nur da kommen
ja noch nie
dollar und mir ist wieder sieht das ist
einfach nicht mehr an die leute vielen
dank fürs zuschauen was damit gemacht
hat das gut gemacht hat wir haben
natürlich jetzt hat euch gefallen
die neue
eine wolke die neue kopf sind ohne
zucker jetzt offen markt auf jeden fall
ein 6 getränk das war's mit dem video
ich hoffe es hat euch eingefallen dass
noch nach oben da noch die ganzen kanäle
ab hier und dann sehen wir uns morgen
wieder gibt es ein neues video